just got home from a wonderful Easter
dinner with family and Tabitha is in
labor
sweet Tabitha I heard you giving a good
little push oh
another one
yes and this sweet
this sweet goat staying with her is her
mama she's a very old
yes I know you want food
everybody is ready for dinner it is a
late dinner for these guys because we
weren't here and we left too early to
feed them before we left so
everybody's anxious for their
dinner but Tabitha is having a special
time
not sure how much of this I'll be able
to film as it's already pretty dark out
here
and I've got to figure out
[Music]
yes we've got to figure out some things
so I'm gonna get my puppy pads and
towels
oh
how sweet is that Mama taking care of
her baby
not sure if you can tell but there are
Hooves presenting I'm looking for a nose
shortly
so that it'll be a good easy birth
and Ruby is trying to help mama let her
do her thing
good girl
good girl because this is active labor
I'm not gonna try to move her to the
birthing stall until the babies come I'm
just gonna make sure they have a nice
clean spot to be delivered looks like
she's gonna find that on her own she
knows what to do her instincts are good
even with this being her first
freshening
and her sweet old lady mama
Ruby wants to help
Ruby is retired for quite some time now
she's a lot older than the rest of the
goats
here we go
looks like
a nose is trying to
I won't interfere unless I have to if
she seems like she's having
complications but she really just
started pushing so
looks like she's going to be able to do
this on her own no problems
I know it's not easy though is it those
are our front feet so
that's good that's what we like to see
just gotta get that little nose
that's pushing
trying to come through once that little
nose comes through it'll be a lot easier
oh baby
sweet Tabitha
another good contraction
oh
yes
good girl
hardest one is the first one baby gets
easier after this I promise oh there you
go oh
perfect
good job Mama
good job that's a big baby
Ruby let her clean
I'm gonna wipe off the Airways
and put it up by her face so she can
push for the next one because I'm pretty
sure she has more than one
well she pushed that baby out before I
could even
get anything underneath her or go get
anything to put underneath her and the
other one is already coming out too so
we're just gonna grab them up and put
them on a puppy pad and let her clean
them off
as she births
good girl oh pretty
oh that's a pretty
good job Mama
good job
oh she doesn't like the way that feels
hanging from her
oh honey it's okay come back
come back and take care of the baby it's
feeding time and Ryan is bringing in
food so she's a little confused about
food or baby food or baby but I'll take
care of it and make sure that it gets
the proper care she'll be she'll be
paying attention in no time
[Music]
well we had a little bit of coaxing
yeah a little bit of coaxing but we
finally got Mama to
the baby's nurse she's just being a
nervous new mom
but she's very interested in them and
talking to them a lot so that's good
inside everything should work out just
fine
but it's really important that that
first feeding the first night
happens
and letting the baby
figure it out a little bit as part of
that so that we know that the baby's
gonna be okay when we walk away but
sometimes daddy puts his finger in there
and helps
to get that initial latch oh disaster
is
sad so the babies have good suck reflex
that's babies are strong
as long as they get a good nursing
tonight and first thing in the morning
we'll check back on everything and make
sure it's all good
Mama's definitely interested in them
she's sniffing and licking and talking
to them
she's just a little unsure about them
nursing she makes her very agitated
you don't like it huh
yeah so we put her on the milk stand put
her head in the headlock gave her a
bunch of grain got their bellies full
and that's that's all we can do for
right now
[Music]
oh you come out from underneath my leg
go see your mama
that's the girl and that's the boy
[Music]
we are making sure they get a good
morning nursing in everybody stayed okay
through the night this guy's got a long
tongue syndrome I don't know what that
is but he's constantly sticking his
tongue out since he was born and uh
yeah he was just nursing where'd he go
where'd you go don't nurse in your
sister's elbow
[Music]
sweet babies
well I may be having to bribe her with
food every time
they eat but I don't know I don't know
if she's nursing when I'm not here
their bellies didn't seem as empty this
time but I'm coming out here at
intervals that I feel like a baby would
need to eat
first fresheners are something you have
to give a little bit of extra attention
to to make sure everything's going
smoothly but at least now she's not
kicking at them and they're nursing just
fine when I give her a little handful of
food
so this is great